i have another question for you guys do
you think because like women we have the
right to an abortion do you think men
should have the right to a financial
abortion
can you explain that so a financial
abortion is basically um
when so if i'm pregnant right i can say
oh i don't want to be a mother and i can
have an abortion do you think men that
don't want to be fathers should say you
know what i don't want to be on the hook
for child support i don't want to have
anything to do with this kid
and if it was up to me she would get an
abortion but she's not so i want to sign
a reign sign away my rights do you guys
think that men should be able to do that
i think that's fair okay i mean if they
don't get a say
um
in the abortion and they have like
clearly stated i i don't want you to
have this child
um
why not okay i agree i feel like that's
a lot of the issues that we have today
as well with regards to that um
yeah i feel like they need to be um they
should have an input
yeah i'm still quite 50 50 because if
you've agreed to have the child then
but they didn't they didn't agree yeah
so basically um
he says he wants her to get an abortion
she says no but since she has the right
to say she doesn't want to be a mother
does he have the right to say i don't
want to be a dad yeah
we've got some based women today we got
some bass shout out to you guys there's
a lot of psychological problems that can
occur isn't it because you're you've
you've now you've now um was accord
enforced
you you're forcing them basically and
it's just out of their power out of the
world and if they can't financially care
for the child them
yeah
how many dads that that are in that
situation get called deadbeats yes
because if a dad there's plenty of men
that would not want a child that may not
have gone into a situation wanting a
baby
but then when the baby's there is there
that's the reality of the situation
and they may not want to play a part
because they didn't want the child so
they'll get caught a deadbeat they'll
get frowned upon by people that know
their situation their family might
disagree especially if their family is
religious and you've got traditional
backgrounds cultural cultural
underpinnings there'll be a problem
there with that
um
so
oh it's difficult because
i think that you have to take
responsibility before the child is born
before you conceive that child yes you
need to take responsibility for where
that
interaction is going
like i agree with you i think men should
take care of their kids but i think it's
one thing to say they should and then
put a gun to their head and force them
to and i just think if we're in a
society that abortion's legal i
personally don't agree with abortion
like if it would be illegal if this was
pearl's world but it's not right and so
abortion is legal so if that's going to
be legal then
then why shouldn't if women get to say i
don't want to be a mother why shouldn't
men get to say i don't want to be a
father because unfortunately you've had
sex and there's a baby i mean but
unfortunately she's had the best
but unfortunately she's had sex and
there's a baby it's the same thing with
like wherever you ate now because it was
a child's there yeah but that's that's
the thing even with
it's there they just pull out the
body parts one by one crush the head and
suck it out
if the woman gives birth the child is
there i've seen that video by the way i
think we've seen the same thing yeah um
if the child's already there
the child is innocent with no none of us
here asked to be yeah we're so lucky to
be born right but the child was innocent
in the womb
i'm not advocating abortion i'm just
saying that i know the child's born but
so
looks after the baby
right right so i i agree with you but
i'm saying in this case abortion's legal
so if abortion's legal shouldn't it be
the same for men
shouldn't men get to have a financial
abortion
yes since abortion is legal yeah if you
want that that balance yeah because we
can't obviously give birth ourselves so
yeah i see what you're going with yeah
it's just a bit of a i don't know i i
totally agree with what you're saying
like the argument you make is a valid
argument it just makes for a little bit
funny inside yeah we do live in a
gynocentric social order so
that's why it's called the grey area
that's it that's it you got me there so
can i just um
a point you made or add to a point you
made earlier about you know if your
stepdad
the the child knows that um you're not
the dad no matter what
i think again that goes back to what i
was saying about a dad being such a
dangerous job you know i was
20 the first time i ever sat down on my
dad and thanked him for being in my life
my whole life right and how many people
can actually say they've ever thanked
their dad for being there no not many
because you just think oh he's meant to
be doing this anyway but it's like
i only deep to only realize how lucky i
am to have a dad in my life when i was
in uni and you know a wall broke in in
what our union house we had to pay for
it and i was like oh wait i know how to
fix this because my dad told me and my
dad was around this whole time so
it's it's a crazy thing that you know
your stepdad would be there so long and
the kid knows it's always that but i
think
when that kid grows up if you raise him
well he will he will most likely thank
you for what you've done for being
around i hope so yeah
i actually hope so
from my personal situation
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna read some super
chats real quick um guys i
who just gifted a bunch of memberships
shout out to you they gifted like 10
memberships
um p4g we got a bunch of members in the
chat welcome to our memberships guys
you're going to see exclusive behind the
scenes content on top of that you are
also going to get the the second half of
the show is going to be members only
chat so you get the members only chat
privilege okay so
nh what's even worse is the csa is a
business the kid only receives a
percentage of the fee sent by the father
i'm sure it's around 40 of the figure
the uk economist if mothers were better
at raising kids why are so many young
people in gangs and committing knife
crimes that come from single mother
homes
kai ken there's there this is a grown
man alone and drunk with a woman saying
he's oh i read that one already let me
refresh the page hold on
um
okay
90
free toe pie how are you my little
cayenne pepper i am i'm good i don't
think that like cayenne okay i don't
know how to take this i think he's
taking a liking to you
okay that's all the super chats do you
have any more questions sarah um
i'll be rounding up you have one okay
man all right go ahead all right we
could do like one more my question we're
talking about if the man or we always
talk about if the man doesn't want the
kid and the woman wants the kid what if
it's the other way around and the man
wants the kid and the woman doesn't want
the kid that's what i want to talk about
i think it's world that the man has no
say at all whenever that child is born
or not like
if i've been in that situation sorry yo
you've been yeah it's it's wild like if
i want to if i'm saying i'll take care
of that kid
and you're still having an abortion even
and she can do this even when you're
married it's my it's world it's wild
i i think
i mean i don't think abortion should be
legal so if it was up to me that would
be a legal procedure
what do you guys think do you think men
should have a say in abortion
yeah because it's their it's their child
being born as well okay you know i think
it's a joint commitment
in the idle world i would it would be
great to have 50 50
with that but
once you were bought like if a guy wants
the baby right
if the guy wants a baby once you were
bought if he's if you two are together
for instance right and you say you know
what i know we're together but i don't
want this child
does he just is he ever right just leave
you after that
do you think he's she's just like all
right bye
that's a big thing you know that's a
that's the same as like marriage if he
wants to get married and you didn't
right that at that point in time
and you say like i'm not ready he can
still leave yeah you know i think
because what's he supposed to do like go
to the abortion clinic review to kill
his child at the same time i do think
women women have to carry the baby it
changes their body it changes you know
the hormones going in in
in their brain in the blood so i do
think at the end of the day it does come
down to the woman but i definitely think
that's why we need to be so careful in
choosing the people we sleep with
because it should be a decision that
both of you make together right although
it is in the women's body and everything
and ultimately it does come down to her
we need to be careful who we're sleeping
with
so these issues don't arise you know and
talk about it beforehand i think the
question off camera
is a good one because
we're getting to the point now where you
get the conflation between
what men and women can actually do with
their bodies versus what we think is
morally right right so for me you're
talking about that great area the gray
bit that massive gray area that we're
talking about see because the way i see
it is is that what you've just said
there is spot on it's your body
so therefore
i'm on the side of if you don't want the
child
then maybe at that point would be the
woman's decision
because she has to go through something
that men can never go through right so
the the the constant pursuit of equality
in society this is where it gets messed
up because we're not equal
we can't we cannot give birth as men so
therefore
if the conversation is the woman wants
to have the child
because you're you're the incubator
but the man doesn't want it that's i
think that is a separate debate versus
the same question in reverse because the
physical
uh
the physicality of actually having a
baby but it's not our body
it's the kid's body it's a unique dna
sequence that's unique from the mother
and the fathers it from the moment of
conception i understand that but i was
just answering the
do you question she should have the
right